welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and if there's one
thing everyone should know about me it's
that I love dogs like this one and this
one right here welcome back to New
rockstars I'm Pugsley Adams and today my
mom is going to tell you about Cosmo the
space dog don't tell by Bob's boss but I
totally wrote this script like Peggy
said one of my favorite parts of the
Guardians of the Galaxy holiday special
was finally seeing and hearing more of
Cosmo so today I'm going to explain
everything you need to know about this
furry friend before Guardian 3 comes out
quick recap of everything we know about
Cosmo from the MCU she first appeared in
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 1 as an item
in the collector's Museum on nowhere
she's a sweet little Golden Retriever
and although I do not approve of Tavon
locking her in a glass case like a
specimen I'm very very glad that she was
at least somewhat protected when Karina
blew up the place by grabbing an
infinity stone with her bare hands like
a goddamn dope Cosmo speaks through her
color and is voiced by Maria bakalova
who recently Rose to stardom by crushing
it as borat's daughter according to the
Guardians holiday spec special and James
Gunn's tweets after a Thanos attacked
nowhere on his quest to retrieve reality
Stone the formerly bustling debauchery
and resource mining hangout for
Mercenaries and space criminals was
toast the Guardians have a little cash
Outlet to spend after their Many
Adventures so they purchased the burned
out husk and transform it into their new
base of operations Cosmo's job in the
renovation process is to use her
telekinesis to tear down and rebuild the
damaged structures but just so you know
she will only work for treats Bob you
know we all unionize we will not use our
mind control powers or write produce
edit and star in your YouTube videos for
less than three snackies an hour
actually make that five stockies an hour
I charge extra for being so handsome
alright that's fair but now it's time to
get into Cosmo's comic backstory and
talk about what aspects of her story
might cross over into the MCU if they
haven't already Pugsley cover your ears
for this it's gonna get really sad as
you probably already knew Cosmo's
character was inspired by Leica the
space dog who was one of the very first
animals in space and the very first to
orbit the earth unfortunately her
survival was never expected due to the
fact that Soviet scientists didn't know
how to safely bring a spacecraft back to
Earth for landing I really don't want to
go into the horrific details but Leica
was adopted from the street and trained
under harsh conditions for her journey
to outer space and ultimately passed
away four days into the journey due to
unregulated temperatures on board our
furry Marvel friend was named after the
cosmonauts AKA Russian astronauts who
handled like his journey Cosmo's comic
story is a somewhat more comforting
alternative to the real leicas trained
by the Soviet space program this sweet
baby was launched into orbit but he
survived the journey hit by cosmic rays
that gave him psionic Powers Cosmo ended
up becoming the top dog chief of
security for nowhere like a really cool
much smarter and fluffier Paul Blart
mauka it was his job to keep the peace
and yes I did just use male pronouns for
phasma although she was written as a
lady dog for the MCU Cosmo from the
comics is a very good boy so when we're
talking about MCU Cosmo she's a she and
in the comic he's a he Gunn actually
made this gender swap in honor of
Cosmo's inspiration Leica I stare at
screens all day and that could be tough
on my eyes it used to be the case that
I'd help my eyes out by wearing a pair
of blue blocks blue light glasses but
blue blocks has become Bond charge
thankfully the glasses have stayed the
same
boncharge is a couple of different
glasses depending on what you need my
go-to are the computer glasses they help
reduce Sore Eyes headaches watery eyes
and fatigue if I'm staring at a computer
all day or if I'm in a room with
fluorescent lights these glasses are my
first line of defense spawn charge's
glasses are backed by science and tested
to make sure that they work which is not
the case with other light blocking
glasses on the market if you've got a
prescription you can get these with a
prescription if you don't you can get
these without a prescription just need a
pair of light block and reading glasses
spawn charge can handle that too on
charge ships worldwide and have other
great products like low blue light bulbs
red light therapy devices and 100 light
blocking sleep mask spawn charge is
currently having a boxing day sale with
a massive 25 off site-wide until January
2nd just go to boncharge.com and choose
your favorite wellness products and the
discount code will be automatically
applied at checkout that's boncharge.com
and the 25 off discount code will
automatically be applied at checkout
this little space dog is a master of
telepathy and despite Rocket's criticism
of her accuracy in the holiday special
his Comic version is Extreme extremely
precise one of the coolest things about
him is that he has the ability to block
his psionic powers from Discovery by
other mind readers and he's also gifted
at creating realistic Illusions he can
even transform the appearance of himself
and his allies by altering their enemy's
perception of their surroundings and
ages in a much slower rate than normal
dogs he does have a weakness for poison
but that's why we don't let him eat
chocolate onions butter or broccoli from
the dinner table even though Cosmo is a
bit of a dog genius he still loves
simple doggy Joys like chew bones and
rubs Cosmo first appeared in 2007's Nova
volume 4 number eight and this canine
Cosmonaut leads Nova through an
abandoned nowhere this is also the first
appearance of nowhere and it's
established that this severed Celestial
head sits on the edge of time and space
being that nowhere is the closest point
to observe the edge of the universe it
became a popular destination for
scientists Across the Universe looking
to study the end of everything like I
said though this place is a ghost town
when Nova shows up and Cosmo relates
with the inhabitants of nowhere fled
into a microverse after an entity known
as The Abyss started turning citizens
into space zombies due to Cosmo's
high-level psychic powers he was able to
resist the abyss's influence so he
volunteered to be man's best friend and
keep their microverse safe this
microverse which he calls a dimensional
envelope was held within a tesseracted
storage Crystal attached to his collar
after teaming up with Nova to defeat the
abyss and its Meat Puppets nowhere's
population was freed and Cozumel
continued his duties as Top Dog of
security Nova eventually suggests the
Guardians use nowhere as a base shortly
after the group's formation Cosmo
allowed them to work there and help the
Guardians as much as possible throughout
25 issues of gotg volume 2. especially
when it came time to use the Continuum
cortex a transport system made from the
dead celestial's brain stem as we
learned in the first Guardians film
nowhere was mined for the leftover
powerful resources within the head Zach
about an organ donor am I right
throughout Cosmos comic history he stood
against some pretty powerful foes Cosmo
has bested Adam Warlock killed in
alternate Dimensions Hull and helped
mantis and Moondragon mentally subdue
him knowing that Nova AKA my boy dick
Ryder is coming soon to the MCU I do
think it's highly likely that we'll
eventually see these two team up like
they did in the comics there's even the
possibility of Cosmo playing a role in
Nova's introduction just like he
introduced the goodest space boy on the
pages of his story it's never a bad
thing to have a psychic on your team and
if folks start gathering on nowhere to
watch the next big Multiverse shattering
event like Kang's arrival we know he'll
help lead writer and the Guardians to
Victory I'm also wondering if at some
point we'll see Cosmo entrusted with the
safety of nowhere citizens inside a
dimensional envelope or a Quantum
Envelope as it's likely to be called in
the MCU this is one of comet Cosmo's
coolest actions and I'd love to see it
play out on screen it could also be a
safe place for The Avengers to shrink
down and hide in once Kings on their
asses and Cosmo really is the best in
the biz of protecting his teammates I
also really hope that we get a more
in-depth backstory on Cosmo's earth-life
training in the space program in
Guardians volume 3. not because I want
to see a puppy tortured by Soviets but
because she and Rocket have such similar
paths in the same way that rocket was
experimented on and had Tech upgrades
shoved into his meat suit Cosmo also
went through the ringer to survive the
void of space and Devon's clutches with
the biology experimenting High
evolutionary confirmed as the guardian's
foe in volume 3. these two thematically
tie in with his Mo and can serve as
foils for one another in the comics
rocket has a contentious Dynamic with
Cosmo at times and even though this is
toned down in the holiday special I can
see these two snarling at one another
before setting aside their differences
rocket can be a lot Rough Around the
Edges but I bet 3 000 chew toys that
deep down he has a soft spot in his
heart for this fluffy girl lastly my
biggest entry on my Cosmo wish list to
see Cosmo back on Earth witnessing the
inside of a pet smart for the first time
she'd open every single bag of Greenies
with her mind and suck those things down
like baby back ribs did you just say
Grady is a baby back ribs dude I am so
starting to regret hitting you with that
cosmic ray you will give me treats while
we leave the blue dungeon follow me on
Instagram Twitter at Whitney puppy
follow my co-host at Pugsley underscore
underscore Adams follow me Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye okay you get
paid now
[Music]